voilà bientôt deux semaines que cette
guerre a été déclarée à l'ukraine est
déjà l'un des des retours du terrain des
retours d'exactions commises contre des
civils d'où cette question les russes
ont-ils commis ces deux dernières
semaines des crimes de guerre la justice
allemande a été saisie pour enquêter sur
cette question on retrouve à berlin
notre correspondante emmanuel chasse
bonjour emmanuel le parquet général
allemand à saillé 1 lancé ce matin une
enquête sur ces faits éventuels donc
oui tout à fait le ministre fédéral de
la justice allemande markov bushman on a
parlé l'a évoqué au détour d'une
conversation dans la presse régionale
allemande il a expliqué que le parquet
fédéral avait ouvert une enquête pour
crimes de guerre alors il s'agit d'une
enquête structurel c'est à dire qu'elle
n'est pas dirigée à l'heure qu'il est
contre des individus en revanche elle
est elle est amenée à établir la chaîne
de commandement ayant permis le
d'éventuels crimes de guerre alors le
ministre de la justice allemand explique
toutes les preuves de crimes de guerre
seront rassemblés et que l'attaquant
russe contre l'ukraine est une violation
sérieuse du droit international une
violation qui est en tout cas
injustifiables
aux yeux de l'allemagne alors comme je
le disais ce n'est pas dirigé contre un
individu en particulier en revanche les
les preuves qui seront qui seront
rassemblés elles pourront servir à la
justice contre des individus qui seront
identifiés comme perpétrateurs alors ses
preuves dont dispose déjà de beaucoup de
preuves comme les bombes usage de bombes
à fragmentation par l'armée russe le
ciblage de civils notamment dans ces
corridors humanitaires ou encore les
attaques contre les centrales nucléaires
donc ça c'est ce qu'on peut dire pour
l'instant il s'agit d'établir les
structures la chaîne de commandement de
ces possibles crimes de guerre en
ukraine emmanuel c'est pas la première
fois que l'allemagne est ainsi sollicité
sur cette question
tout à fait alors c'est pas l'allemagne
qui est sollicitée cmn qui se saisit
d'un tel dossier le fait en
suivant le principe de juridiction
universelle alors c'est un set un
principe du droit international du droit
pénal international qui permet de
poursuivre des crimes graves quelle que
soit la nationalité de leurs auteurs et
quel que soit le lieu dans lequel c'est
ce ou ces crimes ont été commis c'est
pas la première fois que l'allemagne se
saisit de ce genre de ce genre
d'affaires d'affaires puisqu'il ya
quelques semaines seulement souvenez
vous un ex colonel du régime syrien à
noir à cela n'était condamnée par le
parquet fédéral allemand la prison à
perpétuité pour crimes contre l'humanité
pour génocide pour des crimes qu'ils
avaient perpétré en tant que quelques
blindés commandant d'une des prisons de
bachar al assad
emmanuel chain en direct de berlin sur
ce point